et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
eric piolle bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes le
maire écologiste de grenoble et vous
êtes l'auteur de ce livre de l'espoir
pour une république écologique dont on
va parler dans quelques instants on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
l'interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale bonjour
julien lécuyer un bonjour yade machine
de la phase finale
bonjour jour julian nous présente plus
mais je le dis quand même on va
commencer en parlant de
ce qu'on a entendu de gérald darmanin et
de ses problèmes dans la distribution de
la propagande électorale lors du premier
tour gérald darmanin qui était convoqué
hier devant le sénat et la poste qui a
donc annoncé hier soir tard reprendre la
distribution de 5 millions de plis qui
était gérée par la société adrexo la
société privée qui a donc raté l'envoi
de 9% des plis lors du premier tour
c'est en tout cas ce que dit gérald
darmanin est ce que le fait que la poste
reprenne ses prix ces plis c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour vous que vous êtes
rassurés désormais pour le second tour
c'est une bonne nouvelle
comment ils vont pouvoir le faire dans
un temps si court
ce changement qui est important mais
j'ai confiance dans la poste sur tout ce
qui me frappe c'est l'irresponsabilité
du ministre de l'intérieur qui non
seulement on prend des décisions qui ont
des conséquences quand même mais en plus
ne les assume pas comme patron du
ministère c'est lui qui est en charge de
l'organisation des élections
ça me semble pas à la hauteur le recours
au privé pour vous c'était une erreur
oui le recours au privé c'est une erreur
là de la démocratie a besoin d'eux
cadre clair nous voyons le degré
d'abstention évidemment le gouvernement
de gauche qui a eu cette négociation
mais c'est ce monsieur partage c'est
qu'envoient les concessions qui ont été
faits depuis 40 ans par la gauche et la
droite au productivisme et au
néolibéralisme cette espèce de
capitalisme total on ne peut pas s'en
réjouir
je veux dénoncer il faut que nous en
voyons les conséquences vous pour votre
propagande électorale vous fait appel au
privé ou public
bah la propagande électorale elles
passent noël passe par les services de
l'état la propagande électorale non mais
on va dire votre problème nouveau tract
et tout ça passait par acte d'abord on
passe par des militants et on passe par
la poste
d'accord on parlait de l'abstention
julien oui abstention qui est un peu le
fait politique de cette de cette
élection régionale caisse comment vous
l'expliquez vous cet exposé cette
abstention
je suis pas un commentateur de la vie
politique donc c'est plutôt votre
travail d'analysé cela maintenant tu en
vois bien dans les analyses à la fois
qu' il ya une abstention qui monte
depuis 40 ans en france progressivement
qui montrent pas forcément un désintérêt
de la vie politique mais un désintérêt
des propositions politiques
là on peut y rajouter locaux vides le
retour à la vie normale le fait que
c'est au printemps etc etc
mais ce que ça veut dire aussi c'est que
nous avons nous est particulièrement
nous écologistes qui venant porter une
proposition nouvelle
nous avons un travail à faire une
exigence à avoir pour aller parler à
tous ceux qui se mobilisent pourtant au
quotidien pour des questions de climat
de justice sociale d'environnement est
ce que ça veut dire c'est notre
responsabilité aussi est ce que ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui les politiques vous
compris vous ne répondait plus aux
aspirations des français et du coup ils
n'ont plus envie d'aller aux urnes alors
c'est clair que le champ politique ne
répond plus parce qu'il ya quarante
années d'impuissance saissac lançant
petit à petit les gens disent bon gauche
et droite finalement on voit pas notre
quotidien a changé on ne voit pas de
réponses aux grandes questions que sont
les questions de chômage les questions
de santé d'alimentation de pauvreté les
questions climatiques
évidemment et tout cela génère une sorte
de lassitude en disant finalement
pourquoi parce que ça ne change pas
vraiment la vie donc ce que moi le sens
de mon engagement politique c'est
revenir m 2
du sens dans la vie politique et et
changer aussi pour l'écologie qui était
plutôt un message de contre-pouvoir est
un message de lanceurs d'alert dire
maintenant mais en fait nous avons une
proposition d'exercice du pouvoir
c'est ce que nous avons fait à grenoble
en 2014 c'est ce qui a été fait en 2020
dans un grand nombre de villes des
grandes mais des moyennes et des petites
dont on parle moins ça on parle
évidemment des propositions c'est
essentiel pour revitaliser l'offre mais
sur les houthis qui a besoin par exemple
de d'expérimenter le vote le vote par
internet vote électronique même le vote
obligatoire comme le font nos voisins
belges vote obligatoire jy suis pas
favorable c'est ça serait une réponse un
peu particulier on dire non vous n'allez
pas voter parce que la réponse politique
la proposition politique nous va pas
bien vous force à aller voter
ça ne semble pas vraiment une ordonnance
vote blanc je pense qu on a évidemment
de la modernisation à faire prendre en
compte de votre blanc sait on en parle
depuis très longtemps il faut le faire
mais ça ne peut pas être une réponse
utile aux autres
reddick le vote à 10 ans que vote
électronique moi je me méfie un petit
peu parce que on voit que la société du
numérique ouvre des portes à des
piratages massif dans plein de domaines
on le voit là sur les attaques sur les
hôpitaux sur des services publics des
mairies et donc on doit se protéger de
cela le vote par correspondance quand la
réponse du ministre l'intérieur de
l'époque monsieur castaner après la
crise du comic con a demandé cela
c'était dire ah non mais il ya eu des
fraudes encore 175 donc on arrête le
liban cinquante ans après peut-être que
l'on doit pouvoir essayer quelque chose
on a vu aux états unis que le vote par
correspondance a généré
un niveau de vote qui n'avait jamais été
atteint et donc ça peut être un élément
intéressant nous avons vu la démocratie
suisse continue et les élections
municipales le premier tour et est le
même qu'en france de 2e s'est passé
normalement et donc évidemment on se
sent très vite et les français à
l'étranger votent et il ya déjà des
français à tanger qui vote par
correspondance les prisonniers
maintenant le vote en avance et donc
nous avons reçu leur bulletin c'est moi
qui tenait le bureau de vote des
prisonniers nous recevons l'enveloppent
déjà fait je crois que là il ya vraiment
un espace oui premier tour des
régionales
est ce que vous considérez considérer
que c'est plutôt une réussite pour les
écologistes
mise à part cette abstention oui tiens
et si tant est qu'il ya la timide je
déconseille tout le monde j'avais il ya
un an défini trois critères pour mesurer
le succès d écologie sa sélection
régionale
le premier c'était que nous soyons en
capacité de gagner une région
on voit que c'est possible dans les pays
de la loire des théières en
ile-de-france où j'étais lundi donc ce
premier critère dans les outrances en
renversant dans les pouilles gt oui
parce que j'étais dans les hauts de
france pardon mardi mais dans l'île de
france excusez moi merci de me reprendre
même si on a fait campagne continue à
faire campagne solidairement derrière
cette union de la gauche et les
écologistes dans les hauts de france
donc ce premier critère et on verra
dimanche dans tout cas il ya une
possibilité il est atteint le deuxième
critère c'était que à l'endroit où
la droite était sortante et où l'ailé
gauche et écologistes n'était pas uni
mais on voit que la poussée est du côté
des écologistes
à chaque fois c'est les écologistes
qu'ils sont en tête ça c'est intéressant
le troisième critère pour nous était
symbolique et évidemment avec la
présence de julien bayou notre
secrétaire national tête de liste en île
de france
et là aussi il a marqué des points et la
marque et le l'avancé de l'écologie
politique un peu partout donc de ce
point de vue là c'est malgré des
résultats décevants et des campagnes qui
était extraordinaire j'étais notamment
dans le centre val de loire avec une
très très belle campagne
bon la prime aux sortants aient été
extrêmement forte partout qu'on soit de
gauche ou de droite mais nous poussons
le sommet la force ou vernet avec la
majorité sociale de la force de la force
qui pousse aujourd'hui c'est l'écologie
politique
oui ce serait sur votre région juste
puisque vous parlez des régions le
candidat de droite étaient sortants et
les écologistes sont arrivés à leurs
sept premiers de la gauche c'est le cas
de votre région sauf que vous êtes
arrivé très très loin derrière laurent
wauquiez dans votre région est ce que ça
veut dire que les électeurs de viande
rhône-alpes il considère que finalement
laurent wauquiez c'est un très bon
président de région je crois pas parce
qu'il perd des voix
donc même avec un score qui est très
important et je les félicite et pour
pour ce score il perd des voix par
rapport aux élections de 2015
nous nous gagnons des voix de façon
majeure en gagne 50% de 50% de voir des
gosses score dans votre région soyons
clairs si vous avez gagné lyon et sa
métropole est ce que fait espérer mieux
en tout cas le total aujourd'hui des
voix de gauche il doit être aux
alentours des 32
quelque chose comme ça donc c'est 10
points derrière le total de laurent
wauquiez donc on est loin mais nous
allons faire campagne je serai ce soir
en meeting à grenoble avec fabienne
grébé un autre de candidates et eu le
toupet l'abstention ce que vous n'avez
pas cité votre région dans les régions
gagnables 1 ça veut dire que pour vous
quant à lille deux endroits où cela
sonne la somme des résultats c'est c'est
équivalent voire légèrement au dessus
c'est ile-de-france et épais il adhère
ailleurs avec une abstention comme cela
je le dis pour les écologistes nous
pouvons créer des surprises
effectivement parce que une hausse de 10
points de participation mais il faut
garder en tête que c'est possible aussi
pour le rassemblement national
gardons en tête que l'abstention est
aussi une abstention qui montre la
banalisation du rassemblement national
cirque les électeurs du rassemblement
national sont aussi restés chez eux et
donc il ya un risque aussi qu'ils se
mobilisent dans notamment en paca
mais d'autres réactions sûr sûr sûr
pacage avez vous posé la question parce
que c'est vrai que on a on a vu votre
votre réaction est finalement votre le
danger du maintien de la candidature de
jean laurent félicia est-ce qu'il était
temps de remettre de la clarté et puis
de taper du poing sur la table pour lui
dire attention il ya un véritable danger
de voir thierry mariani l'emporter nous
avons échangé avec jean laurent fait
lydia il a pris une décision qui est
très courageuse qui est vraiment enfin
on peut pas dire autre chose parce que
porter des convictions comme cela avoir
disparu du conseil régional pendant cinq
ans et devoir le refaire
là évidemment aucun des militants qu'ils
soient socialistes communistes
écologistes étaient spontanément partant
pour cela et donc c'est une fois digéré
le choc qu'il a fallu et j'ai digéré on
le comprend c'est normal à bord et on
agit là j'ai tout de suite dit non dès
22 heures j'ai tout de suite dit non en
fait c'est pas possible
il a parlé nous avons discuté il
n'aurait pas dû faire cette déclaration
dimanche soir il a pris une décision
extrêmement courageuse ils ont pris
collectivement une décision extrêmement
courageuse ils pourront dire à leurs
enfants que ils ont fait vraiment ce
qu'il fallait pour ne pas laisser de
chance aux arènes en paca nous verrons
bien le résultat
mais c'est une décision qui est
extrêmement digne moi je les remercie
parce que tenir sur ses valeurs
c'est fondamental et savoir changer de
position c'est fondamental ils l'ont
fait en l'espace de quelques heures mme
bravo à eux
on va parler de l'île de france vous en
perdez en ile-de-france manuel valls il
appelle à ne pas voter pour la liste de
julien bayou et juge que l'alliance des
socialistes et des écologistes avec la
france insoumise et je cite une faute
morale et politique qu'en pensez vous
bon choix un peu de manuel valls pour
tout dire je lui ai dit il il a fait 5 %
à la primaire des socialistes il est
devenu le premier ministre par un
concours de circonstances absolument
hallucinant après ils nous expliquent
ils par son coeur est en espagne il
prend un râteau en espagne il revient en
france
bon c'est bon en fait je ne vois pas
qu'est ce qui vient continuer à dire
dans la société française ce qui dit là
par contre d'autres le disent
à droite aussi on le voit avec la vie la
violence de discours très fort sur un
front anti républicain l'affront révoqué
en fait anti climat mais juste sur le
fond de ce qu'ils disent sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai pas inventé il ya
des gauches irréconciliables et que pour
lui si vous n'êtes pas d'accord a séduit
la gauche irréconciliables c'est
aujourd'hui nous voyons que tout ce qui
marche la voyez derrière julien bayou il
y a audrey pulvar il ya un hidalgo il y
à clémentine autain ça marche pas
partout un succès on le voit avec
certains certains socialistes on pense à
alain rousset carole delga qui avec ça
c'est l'hiver 6 mai vers ce n'est là où
les sortants socialistes aujourd'hui son
fort voilà ils continuent d'avoir les
pratiques des socialistes qu'on a connu
à savoir battre comme ils peuvent
quand ils peuvent écraser leur potentiel
d'alliés politiques ils le font ne sait
pas exactement ce que jusqu'à 10 essais
pour voir une nouvelle aquitaine c'est
ce qu'on voit en retient pas ce que
disent les
les gens l'équipe d'alain rousset
incapables du fait que vous êtes trop
gourmand et arrogant vous avez pris la
grosse tête
j'ai juste demandé la proportionnelle
c'est pas totalement stupide pour des
élections quand même il ya un résultat
électoral n'est en fait les socialistes
là où ils sont en tête j'en suis désolé
pour eux parce que nous travaillons avec
eux dans kde aux endroits youtube ah non
vous veux bien mais par contre on
regarde pas l'âge et à des élections on
va vous donner moins de sièges
voilà bah ouais ça marche pas en fait il
n'y a pas de cohérence à cela on ne peut
pas comme ça écrasé le scrutin des
électeurs ont dit deux fois plus de
postes qu'il ya six ans dans plus de 70
pays que petit à petit les propriétaires
du système comprendront que le système
les ca sans critique
c'est là où ils sont la rhétorique de
verdure un peu du rassemblement national
ça vous est imparti antisystème banon
les plus on exerce le pouvoir envoyer à
lyon à besançon à strasbourg nouvelle a
quitté notre tente ici
non on n'est pas du tout un système je
dis que ceux qui se considèrent
propriétaire nous ne sommes pas
propriétaires
moi je suis pas engagé dans la politique
pour être propriétaire et donc je
déplore que effectivement dans trois
régions des régions les socialistes sont
devant bourgogne franche comté aussi il
ne respecte pas la proportionnelle après
on va mettre ça de côté et puis on
passera à autre chose parce que voilà on
est ce que c'est pas en train de créer
des tensions entre le parti socialiste
et les écologistes si on vous entend il
ya un certain ressentiment envers les
sourires pascal inverse les trois
régions où les écologistes en tête nous
fusionnons en respectant le scrutin à la
proportionnelle proprement donc comme
nous sommes devant nous avons créé des
rassemblements qui fédère sur des
projets j'étais hier avec guillaume
garot et matthieu orphelin
ils ont construit un projet commun c'est
le cas également en ile de france
c'est le cas en auvergne rhône-alpes
donc en fait ça fonctionne et en
centre-ville de l'ordre les socialistes
pour le coup ce sont des leçons avec
jean fournier je salue françois bonneau
qui est effectivement ont su trouver
juste respecter le scrutin vous l'avez
rappelé 1 vous obtenez près du double 1
de votre corps en 2015 je parle de
mouvements écologistes et vous êtes au
même niveau qu'aux municipales alors
vous prenez d'importants centres dans
l'espace de la gauche mais celui-ci cet
espace il reste assez faible puisque
vous craignez pas que ce soit trop
faible justement pour 2022 crois que
nous avons une capacité à apporter un
souffle il ya quarante années
d'impuissance fortes qui sont ressenties
par tout le monde nous vivons tous en
insécurité
alors la droite et le gouvernement les
choisi de déplacer sa sur la sécurité
physique mais en pratique c'est une
insécurité et social une insécurité
climatique mais tu sais qu il ya deux
réponses par rapport à cela
1 ou bien vous dit bon on va vous
protéger et mettre des murs et là le
projet de la droite extrême et de la
droite réactionnaire
donc ça c'est la réponse dure assemblée
nationale et ceux qui basculent laurent
wauquiez à crémone clairement tendu la
main vers le rn en bourgogne franche
comté le candidat ait l'air également en
fusionnant et que debout la france donc
il ya cet espace de l'autre côté à cet
arc humaniste que nous cherchons à
fédérer que je cherche à fédérer que
j'ai fédérer à grenoble en 2014 en 2020
celui là il souffle il crée de d'abord
du changement pour la vie quotidienne
des gens il crée aussi l'adhésion
politique nous avons gagné et 30 % de
voix entre 2014 et 2020 ça veut dire que
ça génère de de l'attraction parce que
chacun ya sa place chacun est respecté
et on se sent contributeurs d'un chemin
où personne n'a la solution toute faite
personne aujourd'hui n'a de solution
toute faite nous devons composer c'est
ce que je fais moi en tant que maire
nous composons les uns avec les autres
pour tracer son chemin
ce souffle il vous ils vous donnent la
dynamique nécessaire pour prendre le
leadership à gauche
selon vous nous verrons cela je crois
que nous pouvons nous fédérer d'ailleurs
pas derrière un drapeau mais derrière un
projet mais justement vous aviez dit que
vous déclariez ou pas d'ailleurs pour la
présidentielle après les régionales
restent me donne rendez vous lundi matin
eh ben ça sera après les régionales donc
vous verrez ça la semaine prochaine sa
réponse je vais pas faire du teasing au
sujet de toujours dit ça fait un an que
je dis que je prendrai ma décision
j'annoncerai ma décision après
professional donc je le ferai après les
régionales
la primaire des écologistes bien sûr
vous ne serez pas un candidat aux
primaires
absolument pas la politique c'est
collectif donc je travaille au sein
d'une famille politique c'est collectif
et même au delà de ça il faut travailler
avec d'autres familles politiques c'est
éminemment collectif offert à son fils
notamment tout le monde ça va de
matthieu orphelin un regardez ce qui
s'est passé dans le pays de la loire
pour moi c'est le schéma voyez il ya ça
va de matthieu orphelin à la france
intronise et ça se passe très bien
votre décision d'un quand même
l'impression qu'elle est prise parce que
quand on les votes livia beaucoup de
chose qui ressemble à un programme qu'on
vous dit tiens il faut un recours à
l'article ans pour soumettre la réforme
à référendum
il faut imposer de façon plus importante
les revenus supérieurs à un million il
faut un revenu garanti faut un plan
hôpital il faut un plan psychiatrie ça
ressemble quand même un programme de
candidat à la présidentielle tout ce à
quoi je dessine les contours de cet
espoir infos que nous ne pouvons pas
regarder l'avenir en disant qu'on va
être étouffée je rencontre des jeunes un
peu partout ça fait six mois que tous
les des tous les week-ends je suis en
déplacement en france donc ça commence à
faire un paquet de déplacement et un
paquet de rencontre quand je rencontre
des jeunes qui me disent qu'ils ne
veulent plus d'enfants parce que ils
voient pas d'avenir
quand on n'a plus cette force de vie que
chacun évidemment tout le monde n'a pas
envie d'avoir des enfants mais quand ça
devient massif comme cela ça veut dire
quand même que
il ya quelque chose il ya une espérance
qui est perdu moi je viens leur dire en
fait l'avenir on peut vivre au mieux ces
nous pouvons retrouver l'essentiel de ce
qu'est une vie humaine ne sommes pas
juste des consommateurs ne sommes pas
juste des acteurs économiques un homo
economicus le capitalisme total qui a
pris la main depuis 40 ans dans le monde
et en france ça n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga d'une société nous pouvons faire
autre chose et je dessine ses contours
et c'est vrai que quand j'étais hier
avant-hier à roubaix et que je vois
cette énergie dans les quartiers
populaires où il monte une coopérative
d'achats groupés pour la vie quotidienne
pour des légumes bio pour de l'achat de
pâte à une coopérative italienne qui
fonctionne également comme ça à côté je
les vois faire du soutien scolaire je
les vois faire de l'agriculture urbaine
de dudu des coopératives qui prennent
des excédents de vêtements de lingerie
pour en faire des accessoires et qui
repartent dans le circuit de ces grandes
boîtes et de ses grandes marques
eh ben ça me réjouis je vois cette
énergie cette vitalité jeunes iront on
peut avoir vraiment un avenir qui est
apportée joyeux et je crois que
l'écologie politique aujourd'hui en
garantissant des sécurités dans ce
changement en enchérissant les biens
communs et en portant ce désir de sens
dans la vie politique
nous pouvons porter cela à un mot sur la
république écologique parce qu'on a
envie de vous demander laquelle vous
vous lancez un appel à l'action
collective face au mépris des
gouvernants c'est ce que vous dites vous
remettez en cause de pouvoir politique
nous ne voulons plus d'un pouvoir qui se
pensent infaillible et viril isolé
verticale écrasant du coup elle n'a à
voir quelle forme votre république
et surtout est-ce qu'il doit y avoir une
femme en tant que président de public
parler d'un pouvoir a failli jeu viril
qu'il faut balayer pouvoir virilise tel
qu'il a été théorisée par le président
de la république lui-même mais il
s'était auto il avait auto conceptualisé
ce pouvoir jupitérien à l'automne 2016
check on retient c'est le summum ultime
de l'impuissance donc là où nous avons
sont aujourd'hui hier puis a pas d'homme
ou de femme prévisible providentiel donc
nous devons avancer collectivement et
puis là je fais des propositions sur
l'article 11 juste pour faire un choc
déverrouillez l'avenir dans un choc donc
avoir interdisant le référendum mais en
séparant la justice qui a été promis par
un paquet de candidats mais jamais fait
mais si on met 120 parce qu'ils sont
allés l'y lascives
est-ce qu'il faut revoir les missions du
président là aussi je propose de
supprimer l'article 13 et l'article 16
qui effectue les plus de pouvoir et la
nomination aux emplois publics et
militaires
parce que ça concentre un pouvoir qui
n'est pas un pouvoir collectif
donc oui effectivement nous devons
adapter notre constitution est ce que
nous devons partir avec un étendard et
dire changement de constitution que nous
devons surtout sécuriser ce changement
qui est devant nous tout le monde sent
bien il ya un rapport du giec là tout le
monde sent bien que nous devons changer
d'époque et que là nous avons des des
composantes qui sont déjà définis
d'autres qui sont à définir ensemble et
que pour cela il faut déverrouiller
cette espèce de pouvoir viril et
complètement centralisé sur une personne
où on a passé un an à attendre les
déclarations du président de la
république et à quelques heures des
déclarations personne ne savait si nous
allions vivre un couvre-feu jusqu'à
quelle heure quand comment on attendait
suspendu comme ça en lui un bon bain que
va dire la pav la parole jupitérienne
justement puisque vous parlez de
l'écologie un mot sur la loi climat on
n'aura pas le temps de tout faire mais
elle est examinée en ce moment au sénat
avant peut-être sur une mesure qui a
fait beaucoup débat ici au sénat c'est
la question des éoliennes et les
sénateurs qui ont accordé un droit de
veto au maire concernant l'implantation
d'éoliennes sur leur commune c'est bien
que les maires et le dernier mot
là-dessus non choquer non aujourd'hui
passé ici bah oui nous devons avoir une
transition énergétique très forte
l'éolien sera qu'une partie de cela il
ya 8000 éolienne en france
rien qu'en les remplaçant déjà nous
pourrions tripler la production de
d'éolien en france on sait que via
l'éolien offshore qui aura peut-être
moins de nuisances pour le paysage ce
qui est intéressant pour l'éolien c'est
qu' il ne peut pas marcher six et des
multinationales
imposer une éolienne dans votre jardin
et qui repartent avec l'argent voilà
donc on va pas refaire du capitalisme
total avec des énergies renouvelables là
où ça se passe bien c'est les endroits
où on a des paroles citoyennes
on a des collectivités qui souhaitent
que vous comprenez les habitants des
hauts de france qui n'en peuvent plus
des éoliennes parce que diaries nina du
cac sont pas impliqués et c'est normal
si je viens chez vous et vous plante de
trois éoliennes devant vous les avez
sous la fenêtre mais vous dites non en
fait c'est pas pour vous c'est l'argent
il repart et c'est toute la ligne en
même temps que leur mot à dire c'est ça
qu'on a du mal à saisir que ces projets
là ils doivent fonctionner avec des
pentes citoyenne avec l'implication des
collectivités et du cou en fait ça
hearing fiscalement territoire beaucoup
mieux que l'industrie fossile
les élus locaux pardon décision il ya un
code comme pour tout en fait on n'est
pas obligé de transférer tout le pouvoir
rohmerien le jeu le fonctionnement de la
république l'égalité des territoires le
régalien
c'est important et merci beaucoup merci
nous voir gênés avait encore beaucoup de
questions
voir votre livre de l'espoir pour une
république écologique
c'est le livre qui est sorti ces jours
ci merci - qui sort la semaine prochaine
à la semaine prochaine la voix du nord
ce sacre aux régionales dans les hauts
de france la une de la voix du nord
voilà deux candidates vous l'aviez
tendre ajustant de le savoir
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]